By rejecting the null, we know that at least two of the foods differ in terms
of mean amount consumed. But we don't know which ones differ. We can see that
all three of the means differ from each other. But we don't know if these
differences are due to sampling error. Therefore, we need to do additional
testing to see which means are different. This additional testing is called
Multiple Comparison Tests. So we're able to compare all of the means with each
other. We wouldn't do a multiple comparison test until after we've done ANOVA.
One of the most common multiple comparison test is called Tukey's HSD, which
stands for Honestly Significant Difference. It's named after John Tukey, a very
influential statistician. Tukey's HSD evaluates the significance of the
difference between any two group means. In statistics, we say that this test
will allow us to make pairwise comparisons. The way that we calculate Tukey's
HSD is just like the margin of error that you've learned before. Remember that
with the Z-test, it was the Z critical value denoted Z star times the standard
error. And remember with the t-test, it was the t critical value times the
standard error. Recall that this is approximately equal to half the width of
the confidence interval. But now when we're comparing three or more samples, we
have a new statistic called q. And we multiply this by the square root of the
mean square for within subject variability divided by n. You might ask how is
this similar to these, well the mean square for within subject variability is
the pooled variance. It's just the average square deviation of each value from
its respective group mean. Therefore, the square root is the pooled standard
deviation. q is the studentized range statistic. And we find this in yet
another table. Its purpose is to adjust the whole HSD, so that it's less likely
we commit a type 1 error. Remember, a type 1 error is when we reject the null
hypothesis when it's actually true. Since q increases, when there are more
groups that we're comparing, it makes it less likely to commit a type 1 error.
Remember that if a sample mean was further away from the population mean than
the margin of error, it was considered unlikely? Well, if two sample means are
further apart than the Tukey's HSD, then that's considered honestly
significantly different.